welcome back to the corridor podcast
time
if you like podcasts go get your podcast
we've got another one for you podcast
another one for
you corridor podcast this is the new
intro song we're good at so happy you're
here
[Music]
the only thing that makes me happier
than you
is you
uh we got a lot to talk about today uh
there's a lot going on around here
i'm in the studio as you can see in the
flesh
yeah look at this um we're like the
titans holding up the earth with our
vaccines
and you're sitting there like riding on
top of us
so when i came in monday morning and you
you came running out with like this
this robe on with your face hidden i
legitimately did not know who you are
i thought you were like nick that was so
weird uh
i showed up and i went into the room uh
and there was this box from three black
dot and in the box
is this uh some this swag
rag and it's a robe
it's like a silk plush robe
for a boxer up with these social media
companies very comfortable
it's such an influencer like
piece of clothing i didn't know what to
do with i really want to take it
and then combine it with the youtube
pajamas that they sent us
do you remember those puffy youtube
robes the burnout
[Laughter]
they also sent us like the what are like
those onesie pajamas no jokes
like this youtube sent us these boxes
and they were like
they were supposed to be they were
specifically
burnout themes yeah like if you have
creator burnout here's some things to
help you and it's like wow
okay and it was a thick like it was like
um was that those suitcases it was kind
of like a bathrobe but it was made out
of like almost like a mattress material
it was so thick
yeah it was like comedic leaf you it's
like putting on a coffee
you're wearing a hot dog
and then there was like it was a sound
machine yep a tiny keychain and a sound
machine
with waves and face cream yeah creator
burnout cream and then they
and then they sent us this robe and then
they sent us
oh there was also a massaging gun
we got wait what yeah yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah
from three blacked out you're saying
yeah he goes into that and you can say
okay
can i get that gun
yeah there's a there is some type of
theragon uh
a robe and then in the winter
youtube sent us these uh really like
i don't know how to describe it like
these in this intricate art pattern
from all these different artists around
the world that made pajama patterns
oh i want to see you in that jake i know
but they're more it's more like
streetwear than pajamas it's more
streetwear but if you purchase
streetwear with the robe on it i feel
like
yeah with a little creator burnout cream
cream
okay real talk how do you how wait okay
so obviously that stuff is a joke
okay if youtube if you would like to
comment on that though when you're done
if youtube was gonna be like jake we're
sending you a burnout box
[Laughter]
what would you actually want to be in it
though the video game burnout paradise
um this is great this is great because
what i i'm going to segue what you just
said with a little comment which is hold
on because i want to tell you what
industry are we in where
this in the mind's eye of somebody who
would be purchasing
these swag gifts for somebody in the
industry that we're in
they're purchasing these articles it
makes me wonder like
what what world are we what are we doing
yeah who do they think we are i don't
it's so funny
everyone needs a robe jake we all
have a robe without but it's it's
actually useful for drying myself when i
get out of the shower
incredibly soft it's about the same
softness as the owl
i love three black dots by the way this
is not a bad three black dot
that i i felt but it is a funny like
quirk
about this how over the last year we
were sent two of these packages that
both were burnout themed
yeah and i i that's what i find
interesting and i think it's it's really
clear i mean we can we can go right past
this
social media youtube just it's very
similar to you like uber
you know and these like grinding based
like gig economy
things where we're basically a lot of a
lot of people making youtube
videos right now on youtube channels
it's it's a freaking grind because like
literally
you're out the output and like the
return you're seeing on that output
are so closely tied together the moment
you stop and take a break
boom income just pennies it's a hard
slice right there
and that's why brandon and freddie when
had an all-nighter every week for a year
when they were doing their channel and
you know that's why we decided to do a
video every two weeks instead of one
week so we only pulled it all night or
twice a month so we didn't have to put
on the burnout cream
also uh wren is on pain meds right now
so he's gonna be getting us an
interesting color commentary on the
whole so other than pain meds ran what
do you want in your box
honestly let's do this yeah a time
turner
time turner yeah from harry potter yeah
to turn back time
the the best cure for burnout
is more time more dangerous
in life to not have to be so stressed
if i could just pause time i always like
to say that
or i used to always like to say that i
wish
days were 30 hours long so that i can
still stay up
late and sleep in late and still have a
full day of work
yeah it's like you want to work all day
party all night and then party all night
and then and then you still have a ton
of sleep don't you think that's like the
infinite fallacy though like like if you
had 30 hours in a day it would just
you you just the same exact thing would
happen it would just happen over 30
hours instead of 24.
maybe or
i can just pause time and be like it is
3 15 forever
here's what i'd like in my creator
burnout box um
a nice like traveling
sorry are you waiting for like the
kickback and the question to like return
to you and we just weren't setting you
up
no sam set me up okay now i'm coming
back
we're coming back we're coming back yeah
uh a nice
traveling sized acoustic guitar kind of
like the one you have you know i i've
mentioned to get one of those
uh and then maybe like some comfortable
t-shirts
of with no logos earth tones
i would really appreciate that yeah if
anyone from three black dot is listening
yeah i don't mean to sound ungrateful
it's just funny
like the silk robe here you go you
probably needed this
this in a silk robe and a massage gun
yeah massage gun in the silk rope is
kind of cool i'm not gonna lie like the
massage gun's like a hundred dollar item
on amazon so it's a nice
swag box yeah i will say the best leg
box we ever got was uh
vidcon when they gave us ipads yeah oh
that was yeah
you know why that was nice just because
they didn't write the word youtube on
them
like it's like youtube sucks apple
wouldn't let them that's why it's like
you get this box it's just like it's
like youtube logo on your socks and it's
just like jesus i'm never gonna wear
these
i wore those all the time right actually
wore them i actually wore them
just me then because you can cover it
with your pants yeah you're right i mean
i have a prized swag
were they better than average higher
than average quality of socks um
they were nice and tall and they were
very it was very soft cotton
okay very soft cotton yeah there's a
there's adobe premiere socks that i got
from
a rep at adobe at nab that they weren't
giving away
they just happened to have adobe
premiere socks i never found those
comfortable
i still have my pair but each time i see
them i'm angry
[Laughter]
it's like i don't care how comfy these
socks are i'm just teo'd
[Laughter]
i i did a screen capture for something
uh for some video that we're making here
just a normal screen capture
i open adobe premiere and load that one
file it's just a shadow played screen
capture and drop it in
it just doesn't appear it doesn't render
the image it doesn't just sits i'm like
okay what's wrong
talk to me dobie so i had to flip the
whole thing over to
cpu rendering from gpu rendering uh then
it popped in
oh man all right so ren
uh let's turn this tide
to you for a second uh i don't i don't
know why you almost died i mean
everything's been
everything's been going fine so you uh
we haven't talked about this
no this is officially the first time
i've spoken about this
so we haven't announced we have an
announcement to make
is it going up this week or next week
this week okay yeah but we can talk
about whatever
sorry like literally right before we we
started shooting this podcast i did a
brand
thing for audible going into this
weekend's stunning react with aaron tony
and gee
this could be a good one yeah no i'm
looking forward to seeing that episode
uh but it was like the pain meds were
just starting to really
hit right when i sat down on the couch
so it was a bit of a struggle to get
through
the whole thing i've never been on heavy
pain meds what what does it do to you
i i it's very slow
yeah i'm it's like my vision is slightly
swimming
um but overall
i'm not like high or anything like that
i feel fine it's just
i feel good does it make you does it
actually
get rid of the pain or does it make you
not care about the pain
i don't know i don't feel any pain right
now i mean i could try to like hit my
shoulder but don't do i don't want to do
that
it it basically gives you a giant body
buzz oh yeah it's it's like i feel very
relaxed right now like i'm totally down
to just like chill here on your couch if
you're like you might
be able to see socks on a robe you would
like really enjoy it
fresh
[Laughter]
so we should probably preface what
happened yeah nico you wanted to mention
the story if i could tell a story from
my point of view i don't think you've
heard my point of view
well let me start with my point of view
actually no so
so i was facing a way exactly that's the
whole thing i had a great time riding my
e-bike
and that's basically the end of the
story after a while sam noticed that no
one was behind him
[Laughter]
so okay actually i do want to hear uh
your side of the story here but i'm
going to preface it a little bit so
first
uh we we shot the entire morning we
actually that was one of the longest vfx
artist react sessions we'd ever shot
uh we talked with a dude in london his
name is brian i believe
uh vfx supervisor right herota i think
yeah
uh it should be a great episode there's
a very long episode of recording so by
the end of it we're like all right let's
go get some
lunch i should have just mentioned he
was the vfx supervisor on the snyder cut
and justice league and congress godzilla
it was a big name vfx supervisor yes
yes so yeah and
i i can mention the irony of how i
posted this whole instagram thing about
helmets are cool and like once before
probably less than 10 minutes before
yeah it was
i also have a video clip that ends
probably about 10
seconds before the actual crash well you
didn't hit your noggin
because you had a helmet on i did have a
noggin on i mean i did have a helmet on
my noggin
so yeah we decided to go get lunch we
jump on our onewheels and ebike
it's just the three of us me nico and
sam
let's hear it in dobie apparently and
dovey
there's this well so i'm riding my bike
we're
we're flying down this road i don't know
what exactly happened
when but i'm going and like you know
whenever i had a big straightaway i kind
of gun it and the bike goes about
it can go like a solid like 80 to 10
miles faster
about 10 miles an hour faster than like
a fast one wheel speed so
like i i gun it and i go down to this
intersection i hit the intersection
all the cars freeze and lock up because
they're like wait is this a
motorcycle or a bicycle or whatever
what's happening and like i i stop at
the stop sign
just normally obeying the laws
everyone's super confused
about a good like four to five seconds
passes i'm just like i'm just gonna go
even though i got here after everyone
honestly a lot of the time that is the
correct move to make even if it's
technically not your turn
yeah uh so so i don't know what happened
so i
i fly around this corner i'm like here
we come hot dogs let's eat
hungry for this hot dog and i like gun
it to the hot dog shop
we weren't gonna go get hot dogs
sausages okay so
we're riding along we're fairly spaced
out and niko's i don't know like
50 100 feet behind me yeah so i'm behind
you right actually i'm further than 50
to 100 feet
you're always behind me you're not going
really fast
up to sam yeah and i'm looking down at
the ground uh
paying attention to the potholes and
things like that so i want to hit
something and follow my one wheel
and i hear the scattering sound of a one
wheel sliding out in front of me and i
look up
to see wren finishing a roll on the
ground i'm like oh
ren went down i wonder what happened and
the thing is as you finish your roll run
you landed and flopped
and then deflated so i knew you weren't
unconscious like because
you landed did i actually roll like you
did you did a little bit of like
flopping around and you ended up
you ended on your back and then you like
you just relaxed in a way that told me
you were
supremely disappointed in yourself yeah
i can tell like i could tell you weren't
unconscious
i can tell you didn't like knock
yourself out i could just tell that you
were very upset
i distinctly remember that deflating
you're talking about i had no idea you
would have even
you know you're just like he's riding
his one wheel big size he's got a big
surgery coming up
he doesn't want to mess anything up yep
and then
150 feet away this is the biggest sigh
i've ever seen and so part of me goes
he's okay but other probably he's like
he also messed himself up what happened
because i thought you probably landed on
your shoulder and you're just really
upset with yourself that you've now like
cracked your shoulder again
uh ren has a fractured shoulder
as well i will get to that but as i roll
closer eventually you get up and you're
like kind of just letting your shoulder
really droop down low
and i kind of already knew what was
happening before you said it and you say
i just broke my collarbone i'm like yep
let's step off to the side
and you're like i'm probably gonna go
into shock in a minute here i'm like
yeah do you want to sit down like not
yet too much adrenaline
like all right i'll keep an eye on you
if you start feeling pain-headed let's
get you
sitting down before you pass out and uh
and then sam showed up
and he's like what's up
it was pretty clear what had happened
because your sweater was all dirty and
was it dirty it was dirty you got some
brown patches on it and
it had that like it looked like an
explosion just went off next to you a
little bit you know yeah some good
samaritans stop their cars and say if
we're okay and we're
fine and called christian jordan to see
someone get come get us and give ren a
ride to the hospital
and as that's going on wren you have
your sweatshirt this one of a kind
race for the rail sweatshirt and you're
like yeah so
before jordan gets here i need you to
help me with something like anything run
and you're like i need you to help me
get this sweatshirt off because i'm
gonna cut it off me and this is one of a
kind i'm like
all right i practice getting milo's
clothes on and off all the time
so i should be able to get a shirt on or
off you without moving your arm just
imagine ren's very small
and a baby and we got the sweatshirt off
without hurting him
yeah no i was specifically like all
right let's do this now
while like the adrenaline is still like
pumping and like the pain hasn't fully
set in yet because
after an injury like this immediately
afterwards you feel completely fine
other than like everything's wrong but
you like the pain actually i take that
back
it actually was pretty painful trying to
get that thing off but it wasn't like
it wasn't your body's ready so i was
like okay
while i'm still in this state because i
was afraid that like if half an hour
went by
i would lock up and i wouldn't be able
to move at all
and they're like we have to cut it off
of you we have no choice and i'm just
like
you were very lucid for having just
broken exactly see that's the thing
when i when i hurt my shoulder
previously three or four weeks
beforehand i actually did go into shock
that time
and because i was we continued going to
lunch afterwards i was with natalie
and i straight up had to stop and and
get off the one wheel because i was
shaking uncontrollably i really felt
nauseous like i was going to vomit any
moment
i was like just give me a moment i had
to like hold on to like the side railing
and natalie's like yeah you're going
into shock i was like okay
cool i didn't have any of that when i
broke my collarbone you went in shock
you went to shock i could all the color
drain from your face your lips are the
same color as your skin
okay so from my point of view this is
what happened
i was we're riding down down the street
i have like kind of a new tire on it was
a used tire
but it's already broken in but it's not
like anyway i'm riding down the street
and i'm feeling pretty good we just had
a great vfx arts react session
i don't think i was even really going
all that fast
and i'd taken my phone out to record you
know just like you would
a vertical video showing sam in front of
me i switched around to show me i was
like
do my eyebrow thing uh i looked at the
onewheel
and then i ended the video put the phone
in my pocket
and then tried to catch up with sam who
was already
going way faster than i can go and
granted
i do this all the time it wasn't it
wasn't like i was specifically trying to
catch up with sam that was just like all
right time to catch up
my problem was that i leaned too far
forward because when you're going this
fast you have to literally maintain
flawless balance
and slowly inch up in speed i'm very
used to doing that and i can do it
the problem was that i leaned too far
forward i lost my balance
and at these speeds the board doesn't
have any extra torque
to correct itself and get back
underneath you it's already doing
everything it can
just to spin and so
i felt i felt the nose dip uh slide on
the ground i was like oh
and i remember launching out with my
right foot taking one big step but at
the speed
even if i was running at full at full
tilt you know like
i basically just hit the ground was like
and dove down and i just went down on my
side
and it hurt and i was i was surprisingly
not as dazed as i would have expected
probably because i didn't hit my head
um and i remember getting on my side and
being like
yeah that was a crash that sucked okay
and as i go to get up and lean up i just
feel everything shift and i instantly
was like
that is a broken collar bone like zero
hesitation no
wondering what happened it was like
adrian to find out no
i did talk with him a lot later that day
just getting some advice yeah he had a
lot of good advice to give me about you
know having a broken collarbone
um wow biggest piece of advice don't
jump over table full of guns
but i've already avoided that still
happened um
so okay what i don't really recall this
is where it's a little fuzzy my memory
i remember getting up uh there's a car
that was going the same direction as me
and a car coming the opposite direction
they had both stopped
and i remember hearing are you okay and
it was like all echoey and stuff like
kind of how are you okay i remember
getting up and walking to the side
of the street i do not remember if i
grabbed my onewheel or if you did
i grabbed it you did okay
that makes more sense yeah cause i was
like i don't know how i could have
possibly grabbed it but anyway
yeah we get off to the side of the road
and i'm just like yeah this
this is painful and i also distinctly
remember being pretty clear about it
uh just thinking about when adrian
jumped over that thing
it's just like watch this
runs and jumps over the scenes
i'm sorry uh i'm sorry
like this is your story is not like
funny because it's just like a really
nasty crash yeah where's adrian's like
we're just like watch check this out
you shouldn't do that i can totally do
it don't do it i'm gonna do it
let me show you how far i can fly
through the air
this is like oh god dang it dude
like the next day just kind of get uh
just to like
yeah psych yourself out well i was just
like what like now that i'm going
through this too
that video has a completely different
context for me now i'm sure it does
yeah so it was interesting to watch that
but yeah so
we get off to the side of the road and i
remember you specifically being very
calm and collected about it which i
appreciated you're like all right i
guess we're
gonna go to the hospital i was like okay
we are going to huntington hospital
yep that is where my wife works
and uh get special treatment well i
i think excuse me kisses at the hospital
hey you know that's a that's a bonus
yeah no i think i
i think i get better insurance coverage
if i'm specifically at that hospital
yeah but i don't know the specifics or
ins and outs of insurance or anything
i have yet to receive any bill for this
i'm sure it's going to be expensive
it won't be that bad we'll cap it yeah
um
probably but like i'm i'm i guess i'm
more so referring to the before
insurance bill the one where they tell
you how much it actually costs when i
got a kidney stone last year
that was a 15 000 bill for spending four
hours
at the hospital in a ct scan how much do
you think a kid costs
a lot more than that well i guess
everyone else knows
i'm the only one no kids less than that
actually
uh it depends it does depends depends on
how long you spend in the hospital after
if what type of what type of situation
you
you the the ladies in when she has the
baby
and are you guys taking into account
insurance are you saying without
insurance without insurance the bill was
like around
like 30 35k yeah it can be that high
yeah
and then if you that's not what i would
have expected if you have to do plan
c-section that's cheaper than an
emergency c-section um
yeah there's all kinds of nitty-gritty
details that uh
they definitely do not tell you about
yeah
yeah anyways so i'm glad that uh
you're on the road to recovery yeah
about that
but you were on the road to race
prior to this injury and uh i remember
three four weeks ago when you dislocated
your shoulder was it the same shoulder
the same side yes it is well i guess
that's
it makes sense anytime you fall off the
one wheel you kind of like naturally
try and go into a room are you landing
on your left side if i'm not mistaken
well both were completely different
faults
uh so okay i guess i just want to say it
for the record i told you
probably wouldn't be a good idea to ride
your onewheel after you dislocated your
shoulder
for the sake of the fact that you could
fall on the same shoulder
no i think he more specifically said i
don't think it's a good idea to
race well yes i don't think it's a good
idea to go to this one wheel event
race considering your shoulder you
didn't say anything about continuing to
one wheel in general we keep saying
dislocated shoulder we should be saying
broken shoulder okay well there's two
different things there's three different
things going on
there's a lot happening that on on so
okay about a month ago
right uh we're heading out to lunch and
same situation
yeah except this time i was actually
going really slowly i must have been
going maybe eight or nine miles an hour
we're on the sidewalk
and there's like this sewing machine in
the middle of the sidewalk but it's like
80 years old so it looks all like
mechanical and
weird i'm like that's bizarre and i hit
this bump
we call them ghost bumps basically bumps
that you don't see coming
but this one i could have easily seen
coming if i was actually looking at the
road
and there is a bunch of
uh steps going on above us here so that
is the beach drum circle
it is momentarily
[Laughter]
christian was just like feeling really
antsy and just started busting out a
drumline on the like desk over there but
that's not the case at all
yeah it's not something that i think any
of the audio picks up but oh my gosh it
picked up my brain
uh the what were we talking about we're
talking about your shoulder your first
fall so i the board did this thing what
we call
folding it basically just rotated 90
degrees sideways really quickly
and so your your feet literally just
like pop off of it and i
i go straight down more so than like
forward like i did
when i broke my collarbone and when i
went down i landed on my elbow
and just like i just went down and hit
my elbow which caused my
shoulder uh to literally
escape out of my socket just like plowed
straight outwards
dislocated and i'm yeah
so i'm on the ground i'm like that was
really really painful
mind-bogglingly painful and as i roll
over to get up it pops back in
and then like the pain kind of went away
i i couldn't move my fingers before it
popped back in
it was all fine and so i was like okay
just a dislocated shoulder i hear that
when you dislocate your shoulder it's
easier to dislocate the next time
so i just took it easy for like a week
and a half
eventually got back to where i was
totally fine except for the fact that i
couldn't reach behind me
at all like i've no pain or anything
range of motion was totally fine
unless i specifically tried to reach
behind me in this manner
like trying to put on a jacket right now
i'm just really appreciating this right
now
just making sure yeah cause my shoulders
actually kind of hurt when i do this
from various things in my life but
uh yeah you're right uh just grab this
thing over here
anyway so eventually i was like you know
what can you turn that light up
funny so funny yeah it's a little funny
so i decided you know what
i'm gonna go get this taken care of i
decided to go see an orthopedic doctor
we got an x-ray and eventually i got an
mri
scan and they are basically able to
fully assess what happened
and what happened was that when the ball
of my shoulder got dislocated it tore
what's called the labrum which is this
strip of soft tissue on the outside of
your shoulder
it acts as like a bumper like a like
bumper cars right just to kind of keep
your
the bone in in a socket that got torn
when it escaped but also on the way out
it chipped
the the socket bone on the like the not
the ball but the socket the bottom part
of the socket
there's a chip floating around inside my
shoulder now and also
that got fractured there so he was
saying
basically i got to do surgery on this
shoulder minimally invasive
it's called orthoscopic surgery they
basically cut a little hole they send
this little
arm inside and they do some stuff and
they're either going to remove the chip
or if it's big enough try to reattach it
he was talking about like drilling two
holes in
into my shoulder bone putting some
sutures in there tying off some knots
make it tight give you an upgrade
yeah it was gonna be like a six to eight
week recovery arm and a sling 100 of the
time
and so i got that news on wednesday and
we came into the i came into the studio
after that and we
were doing the workflow thing for the
mustache cut
uh talking about that video and then i
went home after that because i was
i was working for yeah i went home to
finish working
i actually ended up being pretty
productive the rest of the day next day
broke my collar yeah and he went back to
the same doctor right and he's like
what did you do
um yeah more like did you you went back
to the same doctor
yeah yeah oh dude oh my god that must be
kind of embarrassing
it is embarrassing how did he feel
because he specifically disapproved
like was he like yeah how did he take
the minute you get angry do you get
sad like you hurt my feelings like how
did he make you more just like
shocked disbelief like what are you
doing like he literally came into the
room and was like what are you doing
like
we talked about this like and i was like
i also warned you
i am reckless
addicted to one wheeling i didn't
specifically say that way he's like i'm
glad you're not one of the crazy ones
because he was telling me stories about
all these other crazy people and i'm
like well
i'm i'm kind of a crazy one he's like oh
don't tell me that and i was like okay
so basically that morning before vfx
artists react his office called me to
arrange a surgery date and they're like
does may 10th work for you and i was
like yeah sure
like sweet we'll call you back with
confirmation with insurance and on that
day
and i'm not even kidding less than one
minute after
i crashed my one wheel like you were
there nico i was right next to you
they called me back they're like all
right uh insurance is good to go we're
ready to do the surgery on this day and
i straight up was like
change of plans
[Laughter]
no i was pretty clear i was basically
able to tell her like
listen i i just broke my clavicle i'm
heading to the yard right now i'll
probably see you at some point in the
next day
uh yeah and she's like and she was very
like apologetic oh no i'm so sorry that
happened
okay i guess i'll put a pause on this
surgery that you're
already scheduled to have that's funny
this is really funny it's yeah it's
funny but it's also just kind of like
shamefully embarrassing i'm like man
so now you need to wait for your collar
bone to heal before you can
have surgery on your labrum exactly you
should probably mention just for the
sake of the viewers and
audience listeners uh exactly how many
pieces is your collar bone in
oh how many pieces is it in gosh man
five i think it's in five pieces so it
is important to know it only
broke in one spot but where that broke
happened
it splintered out imagine trying to put
a grenade in the middle of a tree yeah
yeah it's a scene from sherlock holmes
it's literally the scene from sherlock
holmes 2 when they're running through
the forest and you have all those crazy
phantom shots we reviewed on vfx react
it's super cool
that's what happened to my clavicle is
ant-man
in your body right now just popping
grenades in your bones
yeah in spite of all this awful stuff to
happen i am
very pleased to have a pretty gnarly
x-ray
the x-ray looks cool at least does
ant-man have a moral obligation to cure
everybody's cancer by
becoming a tiny man probably in their
tumors probably
killing their tumors it was his suit
invented by did he invent it
no his grandpappy invented it yeah or
his
girlfriend is grandpa i don't know the
cannon there
anyway yeah i mean he goes with the
laser shoots cancer in the fridge
yeah that's that's where i'm at and a
big part of the disappointment now is
that i'm unable to go to this one wheel
race which is happening in las vegas
this weekend
may 1st i believe uh i was very excited
to be there not just to race i was
already like
starting to get a little psyched out
about racing i was like okay i'm gonna
have to actually take this easy
i'm gonna have to like i'm a race but
i'll try not to push it very hard i'm
mostly excited about being able to go
here there's gonna be hundreds of
one-world writers a lot of whom i i know
personally from race the rail or various
other
one-wheel things and it's gonna be a
good time and now i can't even
make the trip dreams oh dreams that's
the trade-off you make
it is i'm paying the consequences right
now it is what it is
and you know what it's all it's it's all
good it's all good there's other fun
things to do
great story there's um you can get into
all your other hobbies
actually i've given that a lot of
thought i think i'm going to get way
more into drone stuff now
i want to i want it
[Laughter]
you know yeah next week drone crash
huge shift no i wanna i'm doing a 180
i'm getting into drones
sorry i wanna i wanna build and fly this
drone that's big enough to basically
carry
a komodo or the blackmagic cinema camera
i thought you
i thought there was some contact that we
had where
this guy had a drone that was big enough
for you to get on
yes so you may have seen this dude on
tick tock or instagram recently his name
is hunter kowald
he's been flying a giant one
sorry one wheel wow my brain he's been
dry he's been flying a giant drone that
he can
stand on like the freaking hobgoblin
from spider-man
green goblin right just throwing this
out there you got a drone are you going
to stand on it
or are you going to hang from it stand
on it hang
on stand on it why not a bunch of
why not hang from it like why not like
freaking
be underneath it and wear it like a
backpack
oh like hang on arguably i feel like all
these solutions put you very close to a
bunch of spinning knives
oh yeah well they're plastic knives well
here's the thing when you land
they're like ceramic knives yeah moving
at like dozens of thousands of rpms
yeah hanging underneath as far as
stability goes
there's no difference hanging or
standing on top of a drone like
attaching it to your head
like it's a helmet mounted drone you
just put chin strap
and then it just goes
you have such big neck muscles i've
given thought to like some sort of like
backpack design where it like literally
unfolds out like wings but they're just
a bunch of like drone motors
and flying around like that no you need
to have it like be a whole like body
sized
like like what is it like just like a
slab
or like that comes down and like you put
your heels on it you know it's like
it's like was like being in a standing
torture lady gaga in one of those and
flew her across the stage at a fashion
show
what really yeah was it like did just
like a drone
like no i mean they're trying to make it
like oh it's the first drone that flies
a person but like
it was a little lame because they didn't
want to lift her up very high i mean
reasonably hovering a few injuries the
biggest takeaway i took away from flying
that jet pack a year ago
uh because i asked richard the guy who
made the jet pack i was like how high
can he go and he's like well i can go
to the stratosphere if i wanted to but
realistically we never go
any higher than we're willing to fall
right yeah so it's like
in that situation when you're flying
lady gaga it's like
don't lift her any higher than she's
willing to fall
here we go niko's showing oh i see i
remember seeing this clip was this that
the super bowl
it's a giant uh where was this it's a
fashion show
so that's kind of what i was talking
about though
she's like two feet up this is a giant
like white thing with ducted
blade guards if people want to see that
what's it called
um it is called lady gaga introduces
volantis the world's first flying just
just type
lady gaga drone drone dress
she must have been terrified
i don't know she seems pretty
adventurous
so yeah uh this dude hunter kowald i i
hit him up about a month ago
it was it was before his his video
dropped where he's like flying through
traffic and he went to like some
some influencers house party and whatnot
did they all have ropes on them
they might it was like a pool party yeah
he uh it's actually a really cool drone
i hit him up
uh being like maybe we can make some
sort of video together he seemed
interested
i'm working on this attack on titan
thing for now let's uh
reconnect once i'm closer to being done
with that and then we can
we can do it um is that what's currently
showing
that's not the same guy that's a
different guy
um they're calling first no
uh i have a question in the interim what
is that ball for
oh this is a stress ball oh so
one of the things about having your arm
in a sling all day is that
it kind of like messes with your muscles
in your hand
so i like just
sorry hold up i just activated the wrong
muscle um
yeah it's a stress ball you just squeeze
it to kind of get blood pumping through
your muscles a little bit here um
yeah one of the hardest things to get
used to about having a broken clavicle
is all of all of the ways you use two
hands without ever
without ever realizing it yeah and so
i'm slowly getting used to using one
hand but it's still like i accidentally
activate
some muscle without meaning to like i'll
just like adjust somehow or
or reflexively do it and it just like it
tugs on a bone
i was like ah it's very painful but only
for like
half of some people sitting around you
in the office like are working on the
computer then every once in a while
once in a while just like i know
i'm trying not to laugh right now but
that's it's
getting me hopefully one day i don't
have an injury like that
i'm at a point now where it's usually
just manifesting as like a cross
between a a gasp and a hiccup
so i'm just i'll be like
[Laughter]
i think we'd all give our impressions of
what ren sounds like when he lightly
hurts himself this is it's very quick
it's very short
that's what that's what that's what you
did earlier and like a second ago and
that's
why i was doing this because i was like
you should let out a huge one
dude every now and then it'll get bad
because it's like i will move
just the right way and the bones will
literally shift and so my
my like relaxed state here is just
incredibly uncomfortable
like it feels like my skin is about to
rip because it's like so tight
uh and then eventually i just have to
keep adjusting until i get the bones
kind of like not hurting anymore
every once in a while i'll just go yikes
yikes
damn dude yeah sorry we're not making
fun we're it's we're having fun together
yeah i'm glad you feel that way yeah no
i i'm honestly like very happy that i've
been able to be
in at least as much of a positive mood
as i've been in
uh because well you know if you have to
deal with it somewhere in other words
you'll enjoy it yeah
gotta see the positive of it yeah so i
mean
it's it sucks obviously and and it sucks
for the next few months but
um i don't know i don't feel bad about
it anymore i i felt
very disappointed for a while yeah
yeah everybody told us the story too
yeah i'm sure everybody's wondering and
now i have like a nice definitive
whole story here yeah when i think about
the actual action i'm just like it's
just
dang man it's worth mentioning the
mustache cut is probably out at the time
of listening to this so if you
have not seen it people should probably
go check it out oh yeah and
people get to look forward to the attack
on titan video coming soon as well yes
okay so that video got pushed a week uh
and
oh my god i'm happy for that um
so because of that we are able to
actually do a little bit
extra for the entry we didn't have any
intro before now and all
of these videos i've made always have
some sort of interesting opening shot
and we ended up coming up with this idea
that i'm i'm very pleased with uh
to open the video with it's on youtube
today yeah that was what we saw on the
green screen today
did you do additional motion capture for
the other stuff you had to do
uh we haven't done any motion capture
yet okay are you still planning to
oh yeah absolutely i mean i can't do it
anymore unfortunately
so i'm gonna have to like really coach
peter specifically what i have in mind
because i have like
i have it very precisely choreographed
in my mind peter's just been up there
watching videos of you for the last two
days
just trying to understand your movements
yeah
i'm excited for this video because i got
covered
um and during that time uh because i was
locked away
from the rest of my family i could live
a bachelor
lifestyle that's right including i want
to binge
attack of titan oh nice except for the
final episode of
i haven't watched the final episode yeti
the first half of season four yeah
episode 15 this morning so 16 will i i
don't know when i'll see it but
point being incredible show i've been
putting that off for
years i watched the first season i
started season two and i was just like
ugh and then i had kids
i had no time it was too violent to
watch with gideon
but oh my god it is clear it is such an
incredible show
if you're listening to this podcast
right now and haven't watched it
it is amazing so go check it out
how many episodes have have we done now
where we've endorsed watching
attack on titan not enough all right sam
is attacking titan better than game of
thrones yes
really i agree so far yeah i mean once
again they could totally like
[ __ ] the bed yeah we'll see it seems it
seems like
no one's trying to hire the writers to
make star wars and they're all getting
high and mighty
so well also don't forget the source
material is done
yes for game of thrones that show was
incredible
up until they started having to write
their own material and then that's a
gamble they took
that's a gamble they took but and i have
read the all of the manga i know what
happens
for the rest of the show and i'm just
gonna say i think it delivers
good basically has the founding titan's
memories within him he has the founding
memories wow uh
i make one reference in this attack on
titan video
to uh any potential future
titans that might be seen in in the
second half of the season i guess
they're like it's the final season oh jk
we only did half of it i love how it's
the second half he's gonna come out next
season and then it's like to be
continued
wow it's like maybe just japanese shows
like are real have like 30 episodes
normally or something commonly expected
that the final season is
like so 16 hits and they're like no
that's only the first half of the season
and then we take a break for like six to
eight months
it's like okay whatever they do for
season three they do that for harry
potter
i guess so that was a little different
well either way
it's a cool show um but yeah it's uh
i make it it's a non-spoiler reference
it's one of those kind of references
that like if
if you've read the manga and you know
what's coming you're like i get it
if you have no idea what's coming you're
not gonna get it at all and it's also
not going to color
your expectations at all so i
i feel like i may i found like the good
middle ground because i'm specifically
trying
to we're not going to put any spoilers
we're going to have to read the comments
for that one by the way yeah
i'm going to do this probably a good
idea yeah i mean honestly i think it's a
good idea that you didn't put in the
slime titan
or uh like the jumping titan i think
those are spider titans
spiders oh wait sorry i'm just don't
you're just kidding there's no slime
times
you know the mohawk titan never showed
up no he never did
i think it's season four the second half
of season four we got we're getting
mohawk titan finally
and then we're getting goober titan i
know mohawk time was in the main
titan goober dude i'm just i'm making
i'm literally writing the show
right now pulling a dd wise
i will say you guys have absolutely no
idea what's in store for you
you better hold on to your shoelaces
buckle up
sam i uh you just mentioned you had
coveted and you lived a bachelor life
i'm actually really curious to hear
like how that worked for you so you i
imagine we're very
concerned and careful about not getting
sarah infected with the virus
so did you literally just spend like
straight up two weeks like separated
in the same house not quite but
basically um so we got vaccines
and then it turns out that a couple of
us had covered and so i was getting
negative tests
almost daily mm-hmm well not daily it
was like 72 hours
yeah but basically i was like oh this is
bad
and then i'm like get negative test day
two
negative test day three positive test
i'm like god damn it
right and so i mentioned that like right
now l.a county has like
one and a half people out of a hundred
thousand that test
yeah yeah so like i wake up i get the
positive test i'm hanging out with the
kids i'm like
well i got covered and i'm just playing
with the kids and then so sarah like i'm
letting
her sleep in sunday morning and she
comes up around nine i'm like
bad news got covered positive right now
and she's like really i was like yeah
it's like
she's like well you better go downstairs
then it's like yeah i guess i'm going
downstairs
so i go downstairs and i bring a bunch
of stuff i'm like wait hold on let me
get a bunch of stuff
so i get everything i can and then i go
downstairs for the day and i'm like all
right well i just sat around
on an ipad watching attack on titan and
then that next day hits
and we're like i'm like i i feel fine
i'm gonna go get another test just to
make sure so i go out and get a rapid
test
the doctor comes down he's like now yeah
you're still positive i'm like damn it
so i'm like all right well the studio
hasn't opened so i drive all the way to
the studio before everyone gets here
monday morning and i like i'm like i
just take one of these nice laptops
i take that i get some gear because i
mean so i can work remotely yeah
and then i basically just proceeded to
spend basically
that monday through friday just down in
this bedroom
in our house um i did come up to play
with the kids outside
a few times during the week uh but the
end of the week is like i actually
was kind of sick for like two days yeah
i remember there was a time there when
you're actually like i
don't feel well at all yeah i was fine
monday tuesday wednesday wednesday night
i was like
and then thursday and friday i was like
ooh i feel like crap saturday morning
rolls around i like
100 normal like i start doing push-ups
and exercising in this bedroom like a
prison cell
i'm like and then basically on that
saturday i was like
i feel great and so i start hanging out
with the kids i'll keep them i keep my
mask on for the next
i was gonna i was actually gonna ask
about that too so it's like i assume you
have to like go to the kitchen at some
point to get food so like
the rest of the house really most of the
time and i would sneak up like an elf at
10 p.m
to do dishes and help out with some
stuff while everyone was asleep
if you left your basement dwelling yeah
i wore a mask around
the kids but you know once i hit like
day 7
then i was like i i think i'm good like
i feel pretty good so i
you know once again it was my risk to
take but i basically
started hanging out with everyone almost
all day on day seven
day eight and then and by everyone you
mean your family and then day nine i was
like
pretty pretty last night i went to a
nursing home and checking hands with
everybody
i think day nine i was last with the
mask and then day ten i was just like
well day ten is the day yeah end of year
yeah but you know
it was a bunch of these things too like
an expiration date on a carton of milk
it's like
day 10 sarah was getting tests too
we were playing kind of cautious and
obviously you know also sarah's 10 like
what 13 days in the video she had also
had a vaccine the same time i did so it
was kicking in by the time i was getting
out of that so
yeah i mean the kids were the only thing
to worry about but
kids their kids basically statistically
don't
so get get severe covet even moderate
covid
yeah so i i just don't want him to
spread it though yeah but it's like
they're not seeing anyone else
yeah we were we're doing that with what
i'll do
yeah i can't talk yeah we we
made up our own rules based off of our
information so and they worked so right
yeah no totally i think that's that's
great
i was just like man so you must have
just like hung out
for a while just kind of like i was like
i can't wait to catch up on all these
quest two games and day two i was like
the question
sucks
i'm like playing all these games like
this is boring this is i'm so
bored 95 of quest 2 games are like the
same old boring target
so then that's when i got cyberpunk 2077
and i played that and i was like this
game is like a solid like
six out of ten and then keanu reeves has
the best performance
in his life in that game like like
he acts in that game and his voice
acting is so much better than almost
everything i've ever
john wick is like a baby's first like
script
really acting lesson for john keanu
reeves whereas
2077 it's like it's like perfectly
tailored to his personality
and i don't know like his voice acting
is like awesome and perfect flawless
and unlike in john wick or like others
movies every once while you're like ah
i'm getting keanu like i'm not buying
the character anymore and like
in cyberpunk it's like no it's like pure
like character
it's johnny appleseed or whatever
[Laughter]
you've also just been like pumping out
those freaking unreal
shots just like left and right i feel
like we've been working on that non-stop
i was doing that a lot monday through
wednesday that week i was cranking on
that and then now i'm back and
it's almost it's almost done actually i
can say that i literally haven't seen
anything about i mean other than what
you post on discord like i never read
the script i don't know the concept that
well you're watching like this is cool
and then when the jokes happen you'll be
like
yep okay yeah man
it's about the best you can hope for
honestly when people watch your stuff
yeah
nico did you already talk about your uh
covet experience at home
not really uh i mean i'll just i'll skim
through it lightly
but basically it's the same as sam's you
know i
found out i was positive and uh
see you later going to the room now
don't hang out with me anymore yeah i
was more sick so i came down with uh
symptoms
sooner than sam did um like two days
sooner so
yeah everyone you tested positive like
two days before yeah i
started coming down symptoms wednesday
night which i thought was from the
vaccine that i got on wednesday
tested positive on thursday and i was
sick through
probably the vaccine though because when
i got my vaccine on thursday i felt like
ass well i think the vaccine was way
worse triggered the symptoms to come on
before they might have you know more
severely uh but yeah it took about four
to five days before i
stopped really feeling sick and it took
about another three to four days before
i stopped feeling really tired um i'm
still like
a little tired but it's really not that
bad um
like but you can't you can't say it's
coveted anymore that's the thing not
anymore
you can't complain about it we still
don't fully understand the long lasting
effects of kova like
people are actually saying that they are
still suffering from lethargy
months after they got coveted like look
my taste isn't the best but
it's not gonna stop me from eating i'm
just saying yeah i'm not i'm not
suffering any like really long-term
effects or anything like that yeah
i had like a 10 out of 10 covet
experience to be totally honest
i wasn't sick i didn't feel bad i didn't
have a fever i got to play video games
and watch ipad videos yeah i mean like
my body guys
like i'm sorry i it was it's all because
we got that vaccine that week and so it
just probably turbocharged everything i
still just
can't believe what happened like too bad
that we got it
i was hoping we'd make it through that
game wait literally like you literally
was you who shared the onion article
that said that was like literally titled
cdc unveils new information that it's
actually pretty embarrassing if you get
coveted at this point yeah yeah exactly
yeah yeah yeah that was the one and then
the other one was like the runner at the
finish line the two people running to
the finish line
it's like someone's posting they're like
ah this is unique oh and then griffin
gets
test positive
yeah i know this is the face planning at
the finish line man
for real yeah because it's like we all
got the vaccine
like on that day that we all tested
positive the next day we almost made it
we almost made it ah it's so dumb i'm
dang it well then
i think we've been pretty good about
like wearing masks around each other
there was a period of time last year
like last summer where honestly we
weren't really that good about it and we
were being called out about it on the
comments and then once the fall hit we
uh the numbers were really low in
elliott they were but as the numbers
started rising and
and and whatnot we're like you know what
we got to do our thing we got to set a
good example and so we did
in all of the videos from the fall
onwards every time we're around each
other we have masks on
that lasted all through the winter all
through january february march like we
were
pretty good about it and it was getting
to a point where it was like all right
number one no like the numbers are
dropping i'm getting weekly reports from
jenna working at her hospital about how
the numbers are dropping there
at one point in january every floor in
our hospital was entirely coveted based
and they're like now only half the
hospital is covered now only a quarter
now it's only one floor
now that one floor is dispersed yeah
it's a thing and like it's like we're
all being good in the office too about
like staying within our pods
yeah and like and that's what happens we
kind of let our guard down it was just
like
oh it was it was literally celebrating
before
the crossing the finish line it was
literally those
yeah yeah we're literally in that
compilation video of people celebrating
before like
before the flashlight and then
is saying that when when people are
under like a long term endurance thing
the moment of like weakness it's not in
the middle
it's like it's at the very end like when
people are on this a submarine
it's the last week before they get off
they get crazy it's not like it's not
like in the middle
or anything like that when they like i
have another half year left no it's like
it's that last week before you're done
yeah that you slip up and go cuckoo yeah
it was literally just that way that one
day we're like you know what i like
getting the vaccine hard you guys are on
yourselves about this
jake it's funny i mean it's hilarious
it's hilarious
here's the thing now that we have x's we
can do anything we want
it's all the normal [ __ ] of life
that affects us now yeah how do you guys
okay tell me real quick real quick this
will be our
we'll wrap up the podcast we've gotta
head out i gotta bounce here all right
oh my gosh
so once we all came back from having
kovid it was also the two week period
from getting our vaccines
and so we were done right you you're not
like we can't get code anymore
realistically to the bar like there's
nothing else we can do to protect
ourselves like
we're back to normalcy so the masks no
longer needed to be a thing
no like freaking thanos yeah someone
nico came in he was like he was like
snap
and everyone's mask is disintegrated and
faded away and real we were really
looking around like whoa
so how does it feel to not have to wear
a mask feels great the cdc told me today
that i can
exercise outside without a mask
now that i have a vaccine i'm so glad
they told us that we've been doing it
before until they
honestly i i i cause i jogged through
the vaccination site at cal state
uh and so i actually i i wore masks when
i jog
because there's literally hundreds of
people lining up to get vaccines i'm
like
this is gonna look kind of bad if i just
running around without a mask
so i wore it when i go through the line
you know the loop but
you know but now
well it's like i mean like i i've been
fully vaccinated for
a little while at this point and i i
always still wear a mask out in public
just because it's like
i yeah it's a way of like signaling
people that you took you take it
seriously like
i believe i'm someone who would have
gotten a vaccine yeah but the thing is
that stigma of someone who takes it
seriously is
really muddy now because it's like wait
a second are you taking this seriously
or
did you take this extra seriously by
getting a vaccine
yeah he was like that's way more serious
are you early vaccinated are you
anti-masculine
are you so yeah that you have a vaccine
or are you an anti-master
yeah and i'll be honest it's it's gonna
shift don't worry it's
and i'm going to help that shift
people will be like well you're not
wearing a mask i was like no no it's not
oh my god
i got i got this covered i got covered i
already screwed it up
no no i got it like i mean a few weeks
ago
[Laughter]
i'm possible i was positive so i got
it yes
i don't know the date
can you read it oh my gosh
okay guys i gotta bounce i gotta i gotta
eat jacked right now
all right so my household is about this
sam's ejecting out
get out of here and we'll take care of
that so hey i just wanna say to all the
listeners
do your part help end this pandemic and
get your vaccines yeah so we don't
spread it around anymore and we can all
stop wearing our masks
listen this is the libertarian in me i
just got to say this
you can get the vaccine if you want
you can not get it if you don't want
that's everyone's choice it's everyone's
just let's recognize
it's everyone's choice but there's a
moral choice here and that's going down
let's just recognize that's a choice
that each individual has the right to
make just like they have the choice
of where they what they want to be who
they were the choice
you're comparing not getting it to
committing a crime that's not the same
thing
you have the choice to hold the door for
an old lady with a hands full of bags or
not i mean you don't have to
but we're getting to a point where the
availability of the vaccine
is enough for everyone can go get the
vaccine if they want it
and so at a certain point it kind of
becomes well if you get coveted
and you didn't have the vaccine well
that's that's on you right
right yeah a hundred percent but at the
same time i think everyone should
absolutely get the vaccine
i just i just don't think it's right to
like morally judge people
for not getting it i disagree i'm gonna
morally judge anyone that's fine
i'm not saying we all need to agree to
this i'm just saying like personally i
don't think it's
right to make a moral judgment on
somebody for not getting it i actually
disagree with that too but
i will say that if you want to do your
part to help end the spread of cove
and help end the pandemic you can leave
it up to other people or you can go get
a vaccine
and help do your part so you know just
like every did their part to end polio
everybody's done their part to end
smallpox
there's not somebody sitting around
going everybody else can get it i'm not
gonna worry about it
they can deal with the hurt immunity
i'll just coast no do your part
go out there and do your part be it be a
good a good person and help everybody
else out
and let's put an end to the pandemic go
get your vaccine
that's what i would say hell yeah
brother
hell yeah brother all right let's play
us out
your turn jake i just played us in all
right nico played us in
i'mma play us out it's gonna be weird to
hear you playing in person oh man
are you ready you gotta pick stuff in
your string still
oh i got that's there for me all right
all right wren this song's for you
okay
how it starts sorry
friend broke his shoulder in about five
places and he got a vaccine
and he fell off like a machine yeah
thanks for watching guys thanks for
listening and three
two one